hi there and welcome to my talk on
condenses time complexity in oblivious
message adversaries my name is Kirby
linkler and this is the joint result
with amipass Ugo Rincon Ulrich Schmidt
and Stefan Schmidt
in this presentation I will first talk a
little bit what the consensus problem is
in distributed computing and then show
you the oblivious message adversary
model which is a very elegant and
Powerful model for dynamic networks or
more precisely Dynamic message passing
systems
after this introduction I will then show
you our main results which for the first
time allow us to establish time
complexity lower bounds for consensus in
this setting
consensus problem is a quite fundamental
distributed computing problem that has
been studied extensively throughout the
years
one way of explaining it would be to say
let's consider a group of participants
so for example the people listening to
this talk and let's say each one of us
gets a piece of paper with a number
written on it and our task is now to use
an unerasable pen to write a number on
the back side of the paper
such that
each and every one of us writes the same
number on the back side and the number
that we write was written on somebody's
front side piece of paper
so this task is actually not so hard
because we just could just agree to wait
until I have read my number on the front
side and then I tell you my number and
we all write that number on the back
side
but what say if some suddenly my voice
starts to fail me and you can't hear me
or maybe only some of you can't hear me
you can't can't hear me and some of you
can't hear me
um then it will become more challenging
so what I want to say is that in the
presence of false and in particular in
the presence of communication false
which we will consider in this
presentation this problem becomes
difficult and sometimes even unsolvable
why is it an interesting problem well
mainly I would say because it is the
fundamental fundamental task for replica
determinism so it somehow catches the
essence of replica determinism which is
the task where you have multiple
replicas so for example consider a
distributed data center where you have
multiple copies of the same servers
distributed around the globe maybe with
thousands of kilometers difference
between them and you would like that
they all behave in the same way so that
if one of the data centers is not
reachable anymore then you have still
access to your for example cloud data
and in order for these machines to
behave in exactly the same way in a
deterministic fashion you will
essentially need them to be able to
solve the consensus problem
so the oblivious message adversary model
is a synchronous message parsing model
which means that the participants which
we usually call processes are perfectly
synchronized in the sense that everyone
knows exactly what time it is all the
time
and this assumption allows us to assume
lock-steps during goodness rounds where
each round as depicted on the right side
here
um is well the first phase of
communication according to a directed
graph and then follows by a phase of
instantaneous computation so we do not
really consider computational complexity
here we are now really interested only
in what kind of communication complexity
do we have
um the communication each round is
imperfect subject to false and this is
depicted by a directed graph so in this
picture here you see for example that
there is an edge from P4 to P2 which
would mean that P4 attempts to broadcast
and P2 is able to receive actually also
P3 is able to receive but contrary to
that P2 is not able to send or to reach
anyone with its message because it has
no outgoing edges
it's important to know that there is
also no acknowledgment here so P2 does
not really immediately know who received
its messages and who did not
of course we somehow need not to
restrict these directed graphs that we
call communication graphs
um because if we can if we allow any
graph to be played then consensus is
trivially unsolvable because then we can
just play a graph that is has no edges
and no distributed computing problem can
ever be solved here and this is now
where the oblivious message adversary
model comes in because here we actually
assume a set of allowed graphs and an
adversary can play an arbitrary graph
from this set in each round
and of course adversary here just means
that this is somehow the worst case
graph that will be played so the
adversary knows the algorithm knows what
the processes are up to and tries to
basically foil their solving of
consensus
now the first question that arises here
is of course when is concerns is
solvable in this model and this was
actually solved by kulomar godai and
patents in 2015 in an article in
theoretical computer science where they
basically showed what kind of property
is set of allowed graphs must have in
order for condenses to be solvable what
still remained opened however until now
was what about the time complexity of
consensus they did provide an algorithm
for consensus in the case it was
solvable but it had a rather bad time
complexity it was highly exponential and
so the question really was until this
point does it have to be this way or can
we actually find more efficient
algorithms
as our first minor result we rephrased
the results by culumagoda and Peters as
an algorithm that you can see on the
right side here which we call the
decision procedure this algorithm takes
is an input a set of allowed graphs and
basically it constructs a structure on
this set of a lot graphs and then
refines the structure by removing edges
from it until it arrives at the result
for which we can easily use to determine
whether condenses is soluble so it is
refined NTD is this the result I was
talking about
um so I will give you a brief example of
how this operates on the next slide but
for now the interesting thing to note is
that the time complexity of the decision
procedure is actually related to the
time complexity of consensus itself so
determining whether consensus is soluble
or not and the time complexity of
determining this is actually a lower
bound as it turns out for the time
complexity of consensus which I think is
actually quite interesting in itself
so here I give you now examples for how
the decision procedure operates the
allowed graphs are basically the graphs
inside of these big white nodes so in
this case we have three very simple
graphs as our set of a lot of graphs
and what we do initially is we draw this
so-called indistinguishability graph
structure where we link to nodes if some
node has the same enable or in both of
them so for example here we have the red
node we also add the red node as a label
and we basically
um see okay the red node has the same in
neighborhood in both of these graphs so
we can draw this Edge similarly here red
and blue actually have the same in
neighborhood in both graphs so we draw
an H with red and blue
um yeah we also could draw an edge with
red here but I left this out for
Simplicity
so
um what is now the
decision procedure that basically
um does the following it checks for each
Edge so for example if it is red Edge is
there a graph in this connected
component
such that the red Edge alone reach
reaches everyone and the answer to this
question is no so this Edge is
immediately removed and now the decision
procedure well it could continue
removing edges and it would of course
also remove this Edge because now there
is no connect component there no no
graph remaining in the connected
component where blue and red or a subset
of it reach everyone alone so this Edge
will be also will also be removed but
actually it does not even have to be the
decision procedure can terminate early
because we have now the condenser
solvability condition satisfied which
means that
for each connected component there is a
node such that in every communication
graph of the connected component this
node reaches everyone in this case the
green node
so and now for a second example here
things are not looking so good because
if we look for example here at the red
Edge and we would like to remove it we
really cannot do it because there is a
graph in the connected component where
red reaches everyone has a path to
everyone is what I mean by reach here
and similarly the this Edge cannot be
removed because well here the blue node
reaches everyone so this Edge is some
are also protected by by this graph here
and so there can be no removal in this
structure and also there is no single
node that reaches everyone all the
graphs of the connected component and so
this would be an example where consensus
is in fact impossible
now our first result will be to show
that there is actually an example where
the decision procedure takes an
exponential number of rounds
um what we mean by this well in the in
the previous slide we have seen that we
could not have removed for example this
red blue edge in example one immediately
but we would have needed to wait until
we have removed the red Edge or the edge
that was labeled by Red alone and so
this would mean that here the decision
procedure would have needed two steps to
basically remove all the edges and
that's what I actually mean by time
complexity of the decision procedure and
so
um here now what we do is we Define a
graph GI and by defining this graph we
actually Define an entire sequence of
graphs G1 G2 and so on that has an
exponential number of members
and this sequence has a few Properties
or the gis of the sequence have a few
properties so first of all we have this
set RI which is a set of nodes that can
reach everything
and and crucially the nodes are I have
the same in neighborhood in GI minus 2
and in GI minus one
and
furthermore we have that for two
different indices I and J that the ri
and the RJ are disjoint
and what this results in is basically
that the decision procedure when given
this sequence of graphs in the first
step it can only remove the very last
graph of the sequence in the second step
it can move the remove the or maybe not
remove the draft but actually remove the
edge to the last graph and in The Next
Step The Edge to the graph before the
last graph and so on and so on and it
really has to painstakingly remove one
Edge at a time
since we have exponentially many graphs
in the sequence this basically means
that the decision procedure will take an
exponential number of rounds and as we
have seen before in one of our results
in ethereum 14 we show that and the time
complexity of the decision procedure is
a lower Bound for the time complexity of
consensus so this shows that in fact the
time complexity of consensus really can
be exponential in this setting
I did not yet tell you about these notes
B and L
so B is actually a set of
logarithmically many nodes that is
somehow reserved and will never become
never play uh the role of RI or RI plus
one or RI plus two but instead
um these these nodes can be interpreted
as well bits of a binary number and
they basically
tell the node of RI plus 1 that they are
in one of two graphs so the node of i r
i plus 1 in this case it would be this
will encode zero and this would be the
binary encoding for one for high plus
two and this would basically just tell
them okay
um you are either in this graph or the
next graph but in no other graph this is
important because this kind of
indistinguishability
um that we would have without this set B
would basically not allow us to make
this construction so using a binary
encoding technique here really is
crucial for this example to work
yes and the nodes Li there basically
everything that remains so everything
but the other nodes is is a member of Li
so the leftover nodes if you want
for a long time we actually thought that
this was already the end of the story
that the time complexity of the decision
procedure completely determined also the
time complexity of consensus
and now I will show you that this is
actually not the case so there is
actually an example as depicted here in
this sketch on the right where the
decision procedure terminates already
after two rounds and determines that
consensus is solvable however consensus
plan complexity itself is exponential
uh this looks similar to the sketch in
the previous slide note however it is
said UI here is a bit more involved than
before so this is actually a set that
somehow depends whether I is an even
index or an odd index and also there is
an index J now basically we have layers
of these communication graphs that are
organized in a very well let's call it
an intricate way I do not want to go
into detail here but I can assure you
that this is a
set of communication graphs where the
time complexity is exponential so why
time complexity of consensus is
exponentially I should say so why is it
exponential actually well the point is
that we can arrange these graphs to
sequences in such a way that the
sequences of communication graphs are
transitively indistinguishable to each
other and here well here was
indistinguishability of two sequences
simply means that there is a process
that cannot distinguish the two
sequences so basically it has heard from
the same nodes in every round and it and
also it has heard from uh so also and
also recursively so it's basically it
has observed exactly the same thing in a
in a perfect store and forward algorithm
where everyone just
where the records what they saw and re
and sends the recording of the history
to everyone else
and
this um if the pair with
indistinguishability and transitive and
distinguishability just means there is a
chain of pair with distinguishability
between any two members of this set of
communication graph sequences
and this set of communication craft
sequences has now approved the property
that essentially kills concerns as well
that is that the set of the broadcasters
of the individual members of this
connected component of transitive
indistinguishability does not intersect
um this well so what does it mean a
broadcast is basically a process that
reaches everyone in a sequence of
communication graphs and it is not too
hard to see that actually this is a
necessary condition for condensers that
some process managed to broadcast its
initial value if you remember the very
beginning of the talk this corresponds
to the value that we all write on the
back side it has to be the value of
somebody that has reached all of us
um it's a
another very difficult proof to show
that this is actually necessary for
consensus
but here we are going even one step
further we actually show that or we
actually well we use a result that was
established before that shows that
actually not only does each individual
sequence need to have a spell that was
broadcasted but actually the entire
connected component of
indistinguishability needs to have a
common product a common process that in
each individual manner of the connected
component managed to broadcast
and since this is not satisfied here
it's actually well shown that because
the sequence has exponentially many
graphs that condenses time complexity is
also exponential
so what does this all mean it means that
time complexity of the decision
procedure is not everything it in High
Time complexity of the decision
procedure implies a high time complexity
of condenses but it's not the other way
around so it's not equivalent and this
is actually I think the most important
conclusion here so first of all time
from complexity of consensus is
intricately related to the decision
procedure in oblivious message advers
there is furthermore it can really be
exponential which is also I think uh
quite interesting to know
um but the decision procedure is not the
end of the story there is something else
still going on because there are
examples of exponential time complexity
consensus where the decision procedure
actually only takes a constant number of
rounds to determine that consensus is
solvable
it concludes my talk thank you very much
for your attention
please don't hesitate to write me an
email if you have any further questions
if anything comes up I'd be happy to
discuss it
well thank you again and goodbye